should i stay here not if you're gonna
look that uncomfortable if you want to
stay here
after kim puts a ton of pressure on
usmen he finally decides to stay the
night in her room do you want to like
watch a movie
i just thought i'd throw that in there i
just thought i'd try but due to her
constantly bringing up sex like please
let this tonight be the night he builds
a pillow wall so her hands won't get
curious throughout the night no the
thing is that maybe in the night if i
didn't put you in my kitchen i would
just say zoop and that you think do you
think i would do that to you
this is why you don't hear about
celebrities dating their biggest fans
because you don't know what some people
would do and things can get creepy let
me be the judge of your yummy sure what
you're yam my point exactly
ximena tells mike there will be no
relationship if he doesn't fix his quote
super gross ways she should
accept me for who i am time to talk
about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's malicia i mean
you could show it to me and let me see
that let me be the judge of your yummy
let's get into how kim finally gets
useman to stay the night in her
honeymoon suite something she's been
trying to do since they got to tanzania
like i came here to watch you in your
video
but i came for another reason too
starting from the top
after spending the day sightseeing they
sit down to talk and kim tells oopsman
straight up that she wants him in her
room i think you should give up your
room and give it to somebody on your
team
wait wait i really want you to stay with
me i really do
in your room yeah
he goes on to tell her that sleeping in
the same room is something he doesn't
want to do and let's say our boyfriend
and girlfriend which upsets kim that's
so crazy
[Music]
okay no wait never mind just never mind
wait now you're getting peace i'm about
this you are usman then brings up his
ex-wife lisa you want things to be done
in your own way that was what happened
with my last relationship oh is that
right yeah and he proceeds to tell kim
he's concerned that she just wants to
have sex with him
for bragging rights
i feel like you're just trying to grab
something and go back so even if you wow
that would you think really
[Music]
we only have this time and i keep saying
that and it's not like i'm begging you
for sex or anything like that uh
i hate to say it but as the episode goes
on it starts to sound like it and the
last thing i'm doing is i'm not going to
be she might not be saying please
but it definitely seems as if she's
forgotten that regardless of her age she
has the prize
instead she's just freely giving it all
over to usmen i feel so defeated like
what's the point but now that is we're
getting closer and the time is getting
shorter
it's like we should be we should be
getting to know everything about each
other so we make the right decision i'm
not sure why kim is acting as if she has
not already made her decision in my
opinion this is more about her wanting
to get intimate with usman with hopes
that it will convince him to get on the
same page as her which
never works and if it does it never
lasts long
don't do don't dat me up like i'm some
your home girl or something bye bye once
they get back to the hotel
kim says she's done asking usman to stay
with her and they go their separate ways
but
two hours later
i'm surprised you're here usman is at
kim's door
should i stay here
why is usement looking like a nervous
child
if you want to stay here
uh okay
oh my god like i don't even know if
there's words to explain like what is
going on inside of me he's about to stay
with me finally i'm really surprised
that gusman changed his mind
but i am so excited i mean tonight could
be the night that i have been waiting
for like please let this tonight be the
night man
considering how kim feels about usman
now if he eventually decides to get
physical with her can you imagine how
she's gonna feel about him after
[Music]
she may never go back to america so do
you want to like watch a movie
do you want to have sex i just thought
i'd throw that in there i just thought
i'd try it
if you thought that was awkward things
get more uncomfortable as they get into
bed kim asks us men to cuddle with her
but instead he feels the need to create
a barrier between them with pillows
because he's worried that kim might
violate him no the thing is that maybe
in the night if i didn't put to my
kitchen i would just say
and that i don't think i'm here do you
think i would do that to you you might
come over on this side so maybe we need
more pillows make them really high so
because i don't give you yummy yummy now
okay what is yummy yummy what does that
mean you know
i know that yamas
that's how nigerians are okay
well i wouldn't know so
i mean you could show it to me and let
me see what is that let me be the judge
of your yummy sure what your yam you
will know when the time is right really
yeah well i know before this trip is
over it just came down you know
okay
oh smee you need to pass a little of
that champagne over to kim oh the thirst
is real i love a woman who was not
afraid to say what she wants but the
pressure she was putting on usmen was
extreme i know kim means no harm
but to be honest if it was the other way
around and usman was pressuring her
people would have a big issue and
another thing it's also not cool that
usman leads her on talking about his
yammy that's how nigerians are okay
well i wouldn't know why would you say
that anyway
you're nice don't touch me over the
border who thought you
they eventually turn off the lights to
go to sleep but kim tries her luck one
more time do you wait do we really have
to keep these pillows right here yeah
yeah yeah please leave them i love them
there
see you're holding the pillows you could
be holding me like that no don't worry
about it please chill dies too early
as we've learned kim does not give up
easily
and although usman did not get intimate
with her this episode next week it looks
like she's going to take her efforts to
the next level why don't you want to
have sex with me though i don't
understand
like this is so this is so crazy
honestly
where's my
do you leave now that's what you do
i don't want you to get out with you
all right
moving on let's briefly touch on ximena
and
ximena opens up to her sister about
mike's gross behavior and reveals that
because of it she's considering ending
the relationship
[Music]
i know
[Music]
yes
no
oh
i'm surprised she didn't push mike up
off her the truth is when you're not
attracted to someone even the tiniest
things can turn you off like the way
they chew or their laugh although mike
has no business farting on her or
throwing clothes all over the place i
think the real issue boils down to the
fact that ximena
just doesn't like him
but she's trying to push through because
being with mike
has its benefits
ximena goes on to confront mike about
his behavior including his gas
i'm sorry about that i didn't mean for
that to happen oh he couldn't help it
i'm not falling in front of him
intentionally just to do it it kind of
just was an accident
so it makes me upset that
pimenta is like calling me out on
these things that i can easily change
it's not as bad as like going to jail or
running away from kids or killing people
for money
facts
i think it was smart for ximena to
discuss her issues with mike but i'm not
sure if his behavior is worth
threatening to end the relationship
he's paid her rent forgiven her for
lying offered to help raise her kids and
accepted her disturbing past with
kindness
someone like that is not gonna come
around often so
pick and choose your battles wisely
ximena she should
accept me for who i am and
work on
my faults help me to work on my faults
together
even if i make my best effort to change
the habits that she doesn't like it's
still concerning that she's willing to
throw away the relationship because of
something like that you know this is 90
day so despite mike being concerned next
week he's going to ask ximena's dad for
her hand in marriage
and it looks as if he's not going to get
the best response i love her very much
i do want to
i do want to marry jimena
extremely nervous right now
please tell me no
i'm kidding
actually i'm not this relationship just
doesn't seem like it's meant to be but
hey we'll let them figure that out
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t because we are covering
it all i will see you next time
[Music]
you